well ladies and gentlemen let the
insanity begin Donald Trump's tax
returns have been released and now we
are all going to be pouring over them
like the wannabe accountants that we all
are when covet hit we all became
epidemiologists on Twitter and now we
will all be tax accountants and tax
attorneys of course now I'm exaggerating
a little bit but much anticipated I mean
listen it took years to get these things
so we are sure as hell going to be
taking advantage of looking at these the
New York Times reporting Trump tax
returns released by house Democrats the
publication of former president Trump's
private tax documents come amid
questions about why did the IRS fail to
fully audit him during his presidency
despite his claims which we call lies I
call untrue claims lies
particularly when you know they're
untrue
um that he was under audit I encourage
you to check out the entire New York
Times article as we speak
um the documents are being analyzed now
there's a good CBS News piece about what
is it that tax professionals are looking
for
what do the returns actually show about
his finances is one question and this
comes to how wealthy is he what assets
does he have what asset values does he
claim is there evidence of tax fraud and
all of the other things that we have
been talking about what do the tax
returns show about the amount of tax
that he pays that piece we had a report
on from the house Ways and Means
Committee based on the underlying
documents now we're getting the
underlying documents we know he paid
very very little in taxes claimed losses
some years paid zero some years got a
refund some years so that's going to be
a big area of focus how much money has
Trump actually made
including from being famous that's a
question that will potentially be
answered by the tax returns how
charitable is Donald Trump and then some
of these I don't think these are really
the questions like how lucrative is it
to be a real estate developer it's more
like how sketchy are Trump's sources of
financing I think that those are far far
far more interesting questions CNN has
an early report on what is in there and
of course the the one piece we learned
right away Donald Trump pays very little
in federal taxes despite the fact that
we know that he uh continue to enrich
himself while he was President of the
United States CNN writing the returns
long shrouded in secrecy were released
today by the house Ways and Means
Committee they confirm a report from The
Joint Committee on taxation that Trump
claimed large losses before and
throughout his presidency that he
carried forward to reduce or partially
eliminate his tax burden for example in
2015 he carried forward a 105
million dollar loss and in 2016 a 73
million dollar loss CNN is reviewing the
thousands of pages of these tax returns
I think by uh early next week of course
if not later today we are going to have
far more detailed uh information about
what is in these uh tax returns also
interesting this paragraph here included
with the committee's report was an
analysis of the numbers from each of the
six Trump tax returns by the nonpartisan
joint committee on taxation remember
they found that Trump paid 750 dollars
in tax in 2017 nothing in 2020
and a combined 1.1 million in federal
income taxes in 2018 and
2019. Trump regularly claimed huge
operating losses which you are allowed
to carry forward so the big takeaways
the big questions in no particular order
what will we learn from the tax returns
about Trump's wealth about Trump's debts
about Trump's uh possible tax fraud
question number one question number two
is Trump nearly as wealthy as he claims
to be I think we know the answer is no
uh what sorts of sketchy lending and
debt sources does Donald Trump have that
may have even been a conflict of
interest while he was President of the
United States will this play a role in
the subsequent possible indictments
coming against Donald Trump and will
anybody who would even consider voting
for Donald Trump in 2024 even care about
what's in there I believe Trump was
correct when he said he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue
and not lose support
if he could shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue and not lose support is he going
to lose support because of some light
tax fraud or because he lied about his
wealth I don't think so and so it's been
a long fought battle
it's a matter of principle I believe at
this point where every other president
has released their tax returns other
than Donald Trump but will this actually
have consequences I find it really
really difficult to believe that it will
the next question is does it even matter
if Trump is destined to fail as the
potential Republican Presidential
nominee that's what I want to talk about
next our sponsor real paper makes toilet
paper 100 from bamboo never from trees
meaning no deforestation sustainability
and climate change can be a tricky topic
for people of all ages it can be
particularly challenging to talk about
with kids and real paper recently
launched the little lemurs box a 24-pack
of their bamboo toilet paper with a
beautifully Illustrated Kids book that
tells an exciting story of
sustainability the box is designed to
spark creative in kids create an
opportunity to talk about deforestation
plastic pollution in a way that's light
and easy and with the holidays here the
book makes a great gift for a little one
on your list real papers little lemurs
box and all of the other products are
available in Easy hassle-free
subscriptions or just simple one-time
purchases on their website all orders
are conveniently delivered to your door
with free shipping and this is the best
part 100 recyclable plastic free
packaging go to realpaper.com
lemur and sign up for a subscription
using Code Pacman at checkout to get 30
off your first order and free shipping
the link is down below